so wir haben hier die vier Jungs von
Auletta sie treten an für Rheinlandpfalz
mit dem Titel Sommer Diebe Diebe keine
Liebe keine Liebe aber würde man erstmal
vermuten wie seid auf den Titel gekommen
äm nicht wirklich wir sindind Diebstahl
das Hal sommerdiebe
genau Frage beantwort ne das ist eine
Buch von
trumanti und heißt eigentlich Summer
crossing und auf deutsch heißt
sommerdiebe und das hat der Martin
gelesen Martin ist Martin ist ah super
super hallo nur schöne Männer hier muss
dazu sagen ich wurde e schon von
gewissen Rassisten als Dieter Thomas Kuh
geschimpft deswegen haben nicht
Sommerliebe
genannt g gut okay
und sommerdiebe worum geht's da
eigentlich um
Sommerliebe
okay nee es geht eigentlich darum um was
geht's eigentlich es geht darum
ähm es geht warum darum darum warum
ähm man den
Sommer klauen sich aneignen sollte
Sommer schnell vertreten für
verschiedene Dinge Freude des Lebens und
sich den in die Hosentasche steckt und
immer dabei haben und immer dabei haben
auch im Herbst ist zu empfehlen auf
jeden Fall weil im Winter noch weil weil
eigentlich haben wir ja keinen Sommer
mehr man denkt jetzt bei sommerdbe ist
ah super sommertitel aber jetzt kommt im
Herbst ja das ist der Trick dahinter das
ist ein Trick Trick oder seid ihr
einfach zu spät nee ist ein Trick Trick
ist ein Trick gut okay welche Chancen
räumt er denn Reinland falls pass auf
welch pass
auf pass auf Pass welche Chancen räumt
er denn jetzt reinfals ein also
euch also wir haben ein ein Ziel haben
wir wollen den besten Platz belegen rein
falls je belegt hat und das wäre der
elfte der TE also mehr als 11 soll drin
sein mindestens 11 mindestens 11 und ihr
kennt die Konkurrenz me ihr habt habt
drauf drauf haben wir es auf jeden Fall
aber die Konkurrenz kennen wir auch ja
ist wie gesagt 11 ist das Minimalziel
also das ist auch für euch ein
realistisches minimal okay okay okay so
pass auf ihr könnt auch helfen indem er
natürlich votet und zwar auch hier auf
Youtube indem er diesen dieses Video so
oft schaut wie möglich wenn ihr für
falls seid wenn ihr die Thumbs ab gibt
für dieses Video und wenn ihr es
favorisiert dann kommt ihr schon mal bei
Youtube ziemlich weit hoch das ist schon
mal gut und natürlich dann beim Bundes
Vision Song Contest anrufen und pass auf
na
genau so pass
auf so pass auf wierh ich sind genau
jetzt mache ich nur für die out ich muss
ständig was aufsagen ja eigentlich s ich
immer sensationell ihr brauch ich sag
nichts mehr und bitte wir waren sind
waren Auletta würden uns sehr sehr sehr
darüber freuen wenn ihr eure Stimme für
uns am 1 Oktober gebt hört euch den Song
an wenn er euch gefällt voted für rein
amfs für uns ab
geht's